solving for demand problems suck solving
for technology problems rocks
[Music]
so we have two things going on the first
is we have
a new new intro philosophy have you ever
have you ever watched a peloton um a
peloton class yeah they're always they
always do this thing i don't even do
peloton but i've seen two or three so
i'm gonna say always
it's always like
all right everybody they like come in
like they were just having the best
inside joke with somebody they're like
okay we're gonna start with the ghost
star what's up everybody jamal here and
we are gonna rock it's like they always
start with this laughter to make you
feel like we were having such a good
time you're in a good place right now
okay well
everyone we've got
all right so here's the deal we've got a
uh two things happening the first is
last month we did a contest where people
reviewed us and we gave out a thousand
dollars or did we get five thousand
dollars pen six thousand thousand
dollars to six different people oh wow
so six people
okay so six people won a thousand
dollars we even gave it to like two or
three people who gave us negative
reviews
um
we're gonna if you're watching on
youtube uh you can click the link and
you're gonna go to the end of this
episode and that's where you'll see who
the names are and you have to contact
ben if you're that person is that right
by the way the people commenting on
youtube get a bigger prize which is that
me and you go and we reply to everybody
who comments on the youtube channel
personally they talk
yeah especially if they talk but i
like the people there's really two that
i like there's a great when they say
great episode i don't know what the hell
they say back so i just say like yeah
thanks but if they talk or if they
reference some inside joke or call us
out on uh
one of our like mannerisms or something
we always say that's stupid or whatever
those are great it makes me
uncomfortable when that happens
um i get self-conscious
uh i was just gonna say uh to summarize
yes correct uh we announced them at the
end of a different episode we announced
the winners so we're going to link to
that clip at in the show notes of this
episode so
click there listen see if you were one
of the winners if so email me and i will
get you your thousand dollars and what's
your what's your email ben b
wilson hubspot.com is my email all right
now the second thing this is actually
significantly cooler
so we are giving away five thousand
dollars to two fans and here's what you
have to do you've got to take our
content whether it's like audio or video
which they're all on youtube and you
have to remix it so basically chop it up
into little viral clips and then use the
hashtag mfmclips so mfm clips uh and use
that hashtag on all the popular social
media we'll find you and the and
we're gonna do a combination of cool
stuff uh like cool content as well as
popular content and we're gonna give
away five thousand dollars to two
different people who use that hashtag
and use cool clips or who create cool
clips
i think that's gonna be sick there's
somebody who did this for the all-in
podcast there's just a tick tock channel
somebody created called all in talk
uh like like tik tok and um they just
chop up clips from from the pod and they
just put it up there there's no contest
but this account is just getting like
hundreds of thousands of views because
it's the content's already good all you
got to do is just grab the best okay
we're going to talk for an hour you grab
the best kind of like 30 second back and
forth and um and you turn that into a
clip and they don't all hit but
definitely like one per week is hitting
and this account is getting so big and
it's just some fan account and so that's
actually what i would do is you're gonna
if you just did that if you just made
the tick tock account for this you just
put the best best nuggets on there and
just chopped it um your account's gonna
get popular which is more valuable than
whatever five we're gonna give you five
grand great but like whoever does that
like we'll just employ you and also
you're gonna have an account that's yeah
we we've talked about doing this for
like every month so
if someone's good at this we'll just
give you five thousand dollars a month
maybe i don't know maybe maybe that's in
the cards but uh so mfm clips that's the
hashtag just you know on instagram tic
tac
um twitter we'll see we're going to
follow it all and so did i read what
what then did you look at me did i do
that correctly it's good running the
only thing you didn't say is running
through from now to the end of the year
so you've got about a month to do it i
have a question for you guys which is if
you were betting what is the over under
for how many views the top clip is gonna
get i think on tick tock the top the top
video will get over 50 000 views oh i
was going to say like i think someone
will get half a million on something
the right thing will go by if you just
take something from the rob dear deck
podcast or you take something from the
garyvee podcast the tai lopez podcast
there's a whole bunch of those andrew
wilkinson there's a whole bunch of those
that are good or
just one of our rants or something funny
that we did you know back and forth
we're yelling at each other those will
hit yeah i i agree um
all right that's that um sean i got a
bunch of stuff you want to talk about
you want to you listen to the noah
caking pod i listened to it yeah so i
listened to it in the car it's great
because i normally never listen to this
pod because i was there we talked about
it you know it's awkward to listen back
your own voice but this was different i
got to basically hear an episode of mfm
but just with somebody else on the other
side and uh what'd you think of it first
before i give you my i didn't think it
was that good
i thought
it was good but here's what i thought i
thought the flow was awkward yeah and i
don't know if that's just how the
podcast sounds when we're on it too but
there was something very start-stoppy
about it that was kind of like awkward
to listen to but the topics were great
like i liked the stuff you guys talked
about the the content was great because
i it hit the thing that i always want
which is
i feel like these were just two two cool
people who i would be friends with
hanging out
and i just got to hang with them it
didn't feel like a show
so like you would just be like do you
have a will and he's like yeah i got you
know like i have one but i don't have
kids so i put in my brother's kids and
you're like that's so weird right like
it's not even your kid he's like yeah
it's weird but like you know and you
were just talking about that like
just that
i don't know just dudes would talk about
that that's like oh what are you doing
with your money yeah is that good yeah
it's good but you know blah blah blah it
wasn't like some
it didn't feel like every other podcast
so i liked that but it was a little
stoppy i think that there was either
maybe a weird delay or something because
it happened consistently where i
would say something and then it was
weird there was just like this weird
delay i was like oh i'm sorry you go
ahead yeah we have the opposite problem
we'll talk over each other but that
actually makes it flow a little faster
because it's just like whatever i'm
talking over you you're talking over me
let's just keep it going back and forth
rather than wait okay you go
now i go right and that's the problem
with these zoom pods in general why in
person podcast just like that extra 30
better
is because in person you can start
talking over each other but it's no
that's a normal thing in a conversation
you can kind of interrupt each other but
if you interrupt someone on zoom it's a
very abrupt
like um
it like kind of like stops the flow of
everything for some reason just the way
that like kind of the conference call
tech works and what did you think of as
peter thiel thing that was cool i liked
you know some of the nuggets i don't
know if they're real like does he really
have immersed black mercedes waiting
outside the building running the car
must be running and the jet must be
fueled and on the runway at all times
that's what i was quoting the book so
that that was cool but i didn't know if
it was real uh i liked the poker story
where he was like he bought it at the
pokemon then he had to go meet with zuck
they came back and asked for his money
back i thought that was hilarious that
should be a clip by the way those are
the nuggets that yeah that should be a
clip those are the nuggets that make you
like feel like you kind of get to know
the psyche of somebody like we already
know they have we already know the
resume so you don't need to talk about
what peter thiel's done you got to talk
about what's it like like i've told this
story i think i've told the story of the
pod maybe not
i met a guy
who in college was friends with a guy
who worked under peter two at paypal so
peter thiel was the ceo paper friend of
a friend of a friend yeah a friend of a
friend was was an intern there at the
time he's in college
and the intern gets invited to
um go to peter's like tahoe he's going
like on to a vacation or you know he's
invited like 20 people or whatever to
come to his cabin
so the friend tags along
and he gets there and he said by the way
he listens to the pod so i think he'll
appreciate the story being told without
giving away too much info he gets there
and he goes the first question peter
asked me he goes how much money do you
have
and peter asked that peter asked the kid
the college kid the kid is like uh like
you know none basically i have like a
checking account at wells fargo like
what um what what is this question he
goes no i don't care how much money you
have but um you should whatever you have
you should invest in a company called
facebook and this is back in like 2005
or something like that 2006 maybe and
he's like you should invest every bit of
it into a company called facebook and um
at the time peter was the main investor
facebook
and the guy is like okay like the
college thing like we do like that like
the app we waste time on like the
website we waste some time on like he
was like okay like maybe but i'm not
comfortable just investing all my money
in it and i just met you so this is just
like super direct
and he's like every question he asked me
was a very like
thought-provoking or
reaction-provoking question
and that's something that i've heard
from many people who have met him which
is like he has pretty much zero interest
in small talk
um he
will he's looking for original thinkers
so ask you a question and then he'll
hear you and it's sort of like
if you're just saying the same that
everybody says very hurd like thinking
i think it's
the impression i get is he's mentally
bucketing you as like okay this person
is not going to give me original
thoughts and then if you do have
original thoughts he doesn't really care
what your pedigree is what your
accomplishments are it's like okay
you're in you're in the you're in the
circle of people i want to talk to
because you have original opinions which
goes back to this peter thiel question
the famous interview question he has
which is
what's something you believe that few
others would agree with you on
and he's asking for this secret what's a
secret you know what's something you
think is true but others don't think is
true because any and that being one of
your kind of main questions will filter
for people who have these unique
insights i've also noticed that he does
another thing that's actually pretty
interesting and i think this is one of
the reasons why he's hated by a lot of
people
uh so he's
shockingly open-minded almost to the
point of like
seeming stupid
and
like so
like for example when he supported trump
people were like what are you doing like
that's the worst thing right and um i
like heard his explanation
and i actually don't remember what it
was but the feeling that i had was like
that's logical but like my i don't like
trump and my emotions feel this way so i
just can't go along with it but he was
very logical and he does this thing
where he says if someone says like
do you think drinking eight glasses of
water is good for you he would say like
well you know a lot of people think that
it is great for you because the doctors
in research have proven that x y and z
on the other hand dehydration plays a
role in health yes but on the other hand
um it's actually overrated and you
should consider doing this and a lot of
people think that that's true and so he
actually says both sides of everything
like when he answers a question he goes
well a lot of people believe this and
then other people believe this and then
some people believe that and it's kind
of intriguing so i heard you say that on
the pod and in my head i was doing the
thing listeners do and they're like oh i
have something i would add to this
conversation so i'm glad you brought it
up
because
that's a technique have you ever heard
of this technique called steel manning
no
do you know what straw manning is
yeah it's an example like um
um
um well i can't even think of an example
okay straw manning is basically when you
let's say you are debating somebody
something about something you're arguing
about something or debating or um having
a conversation
and you kind of pigeonhole somebody's
view into like you kind of create this
really weak version of their argument so
that you can knock it over really easily
right like imagine a man made of straw
you could just blow it you could just
blow a gust of air and it would just
fall over right away so it's like saying
well sam i know that you you think that
everybody just needs to shut their eyes
and put their money into the vanguard
etf no matter no matter what it's like
well no that's not actually my argument
but if you make it sound so if you make
if you make a weak version of my
argument then yeah it's gonna be really
easy to contradict it um and that's what
most people do so that's the like what i
would say the common person habit is
when there's something you disagree with
you sort of if to present their side you
present the straw man which is the
absolute weakest version of that
argument so you can knock it over and
put your
your view in place
and what the smartest people do is the
opposite they do something called steel
manning which is even if they disagree
with something they'll they'll go into
it and they'll say you know people who
believe
that you should do x
would say
and they will they'll make the strongest
possible argument for that thing right
they'll it's almost like an in good
faith way of figuring something out so
the straw man is like a bad faith way of
doing it's like i'm gonna i'm gonna kind
of like cherry pick the weakest parts of
your argument present that as your full
argument and i'm gonna get rid of the
the the nuance or the context or
whatever else and the steel man would
say you know
um
trump supporters uh people who who who
support donald trump you know the straw
man is uh they're just racist people who
you know hate mexicans or whatever right
like they're just you know whatever and
the steel man version of it is
you know some people are um the top
priorities for them are
their economy especially if they live in
states like ohio and you know michigan
or whatever and um they've been
decimated for their jobs and they
actually see that trump is willing to
invest in their jobs and so
it could actually be really great for
this this and this reason although he
says some things that are very like uh
uncharacteristic and offensive to
certain groups um he really you know he
doesn't do a good job of that but the
pros outweigh the cons and that would be
the reason you would support donald
trump and so
steel manning is this
tactic that i think if you want to be if
you want to like build yourself into a
learning machine who gets smarter over
time you want to learn steel manning
which is how do you understand the other
person's viewpoint and actually build
their argument stronger than they could
build it themselves
so that it doesn't mean you have to
agree with it it means you have
presented the strongest case on both
sides and then you decide which one
resonates with you which one is the the
more true version or the more correct
version that you should go with rather
than making an unfair fight i think
that's a like a legitimately
life-changing skill i've just learned
not skill but like lesson right
that's one and i think peter thiel does
that so it's not that he says oh some
people would say this and some people
say that so i don't know it's
he still man's both sides of the
argument and then he decides which one
he believes is the correct one um and i
think that's like a really powerful
thing to do that's a good one that him
and other smart people i know do
that's great i'm gonna start doing that
i i and i
i wasn't i didn't know what that was and
i don't actually know too much about uh
logic and arguments and things like that
i don't i don't understand it entirely
right i haven't studied them give me one
other thing i've been observing which is
people who grow up and in high school do
speech and debate are in college do
speech and debate
i'm just noting noticing that that is a
common thing amongst among successful
people i know
and um there's really like i would say
like three or four really common
uh success paths that i like if i look
at a whole bunch of successful people
that i've met
and i trace back down i'm like okay
here's four pats that like
like wow they all like this cluster of
people all had that same experience
growing up that's weird like this this
group had this so i'll give you a couple
of them
one is speech and debate this comes this
is sort of best done with like
um either entrepreneurs investors or
sales people so they're able to just
really effectively tell their argument
actually when i did the episode with
hussein minaj uh the the comedian i was
like you know you're like you're like me
you're an indian kid growing up stand-up
comedian's not usually like a career
choice
so like when did you figure out you
wanted to do that he's like oh he's like
i went to a chris rock show or i saw
chris rock uh stand up he's like as soon
as i saw it he's like i was a speech and
debate kid in high school
and i just saw this as humorous speech
and debate i was like oh
he has a he has a stance that he has to
take which is like you know um you know
women love behind things right and then
it's like and then all it is is
supporting arguments that ladder up to
to like re-support that argument at the
end but the supporting arguments don't
have to be like super literal they could
be like humorous i said it on this
podcast i think that my speech and
debate class in college was the only
effective class i ever took oh you were
one too i didn't even know that you were
sweeping the vacation oh my god that
makes perfect sense and i could and i i
remember all the ones that i gave and
and the really good part is when they
make you argue about stuff that you
don't actually like
right
yeah so totally because
that's the thing in debate you don't get
to choose the thing you already believe
in you're assigned it's like you're
going to argue for this thing whether
you actually believe it or not so you
have to get good at like steel manning
that argument basically um
so okay speech and debate is one i've
traced another one is um hardcore gamers
so people who get really freaking good
at video games like i'm talking about
like competitive or like complete
obsession
if channeled properly that same type of
person can um can use the same kind of
like strategy cooperation grinding
mindset um like ability to like
understand the rules of the game and
then find the shortcuts find the hacks
in the game find the glitches of the
game to get in you know the infinite
money hack basically so i know a whole
bunch of people that got super
successful in crypto they all came from
like this runescape mafia it's basically
a bunch of dudes who used to go
in this game called runescape and they
were trading in the arena basically they
were like buy sell they would they'd go
farm and get some virtual goods and
they'd go flip them and they were
basically digital flippers and like
guess what that same group of people is
really good at crypto it was
early on it figured it out early they
were good at poker they're like that
same skill set applies to a whole bunch
of things that can be successful so
hardcore gaming is another one um
there's an obsession and a strategy
component to it that i think plays well
later
um and these are ironic because
that's one thing your parents if they
saw you doing they'd be like what a
waste of time why are you just why are
you wasting your time playing video
games go learn something useful when in
actuality the skills you build gaming
are so applicable later
i think that there was a time recently
where
i forget exactly what it was but someone
was trying to solve a a a not a math
problem but some type of like code where
you had to like sequence dna something i
forget get exactly what it was where you
had to do like a series of incredibly
hard problems in order to solve
something very important and no one
could figure it out and then this like
medical board put it out for gamers and
turned it into a game and they solved it
in like a month or something like that
no way yeah that's amazing yeah like we
both invested in synthesis school which
is basically teaching kids through games
it's the it's a riff off of when elon
musk was at spacex he designed a school
for his own kids to go to and they
called it astro which is like to the
stars
and it was a school insides of spacex
that only the rocket scientist kids
basically could go to and elon's kids
would go to it
and then they basically spun that out
and sorry the the premise of the school
was
kids will learn more when they're having
fun and they're engaged nothing is more
fun and more engaging to a kid than a
game
and um when they start to play the game
they will start to learn all the
necessary skills strategies and tactics
to win that game
and so like
so they they spun that out at synthesis
school now it's available to anybody and
so people are you know doing it makes a
few million dollars a year of recurring
revenue of tuition base of people
sending their kids there and the
entrance the application to apply to the
school is this game and i played it i
couldn't even beat the game i couldn't
even beat the game that basically an
eight-year-old is supposed to beat in
order to get into the like candidate
pool for synthesis it's like all it does
there's no instructions it's you versus
a computer there's dots on a screen and
you make a move and the computer makes a
move you make a move computer makes a
move and then eventually the computer
wins and you're like oh okay so you're
supposed to get to the green dot okay
that's how the computer went all right
now i'm going to try to get to the green
dot how do i be oh i see the computer
can move diagonal let me try doing that
and it's this trial and error figuring
out process that like your brain is just
fully locked in by the way it's called
um there's basically like an aids-like
virus and scientists for a decade or two
couldn't figure out the structure of a
protein-cutting enzyme and they set it
out to gamers and they figured it out in
three weeks
yeah all of world's problems like you
know peace in the middle east all it
requires is a video game uh if we want
to pull it off just give it to the
gamers um even even ethereum by the way
i don't know if you know the founding
story of ethereum but the guy who made
it this guy vitalik
um who's this like you know
ultra nerd looking guy
super nerd alien looking guy brilliant
guy like if you read his blog posts
so thoughtful so brilliant like next
zuckerberg next bill gates type vibes
for sure
he actually
credits that he was a he was a hardcore
world of warcraft player he was grinding
like crazy he got to level 60 which is
the max at the time and he had like
leveled up his character and earned all
this stuff and then the game maker
changed the rules of the game they like
changed the way the items worked and
like some of his character items like
that he had worked so hard for got taken
away and he was like
so he was just like for three weeks he
was like inconsolable he was like just
so upset he couldn't believe it and he
found it so unjust that the game maker
could just like
he didn't own his items that the game
maker owned the items it could just
change the rules on her and rug pull
them at the last second and ethereum is
basically this global computer where the
users own their own you own your own
tokens you own your own items you have
your own private keys then there's no
company there's no the the whole
platform is designed so that
the the app makers could never do that
to you and he credits that as like a
pretty major influence in his thinking
and like sent him down a rabbit hole of
like why is the world the way it is and
how can i change it i never heard that
story so what what's the uh what's the
last one or two last one or two so
arbitragers so these are people you've
probably met a bunch of people who are
like yeah like gamblers or they're
successful now but they're like yeah i
got my start doing like um you know kind
of like an affiliate ad network online
sending traffic to porn sites or like uh
you know like
yeah i realized you could just buy this
t-shirt you could drop ship this t-shirt
and i could get this 10
vig just in the arbitrage between this
ad network and this place this click and
that click they just love the action
they love the action they learn how to
do internet marketing at a like very
fundamental level
and um and at some point they get sort
of disillusioned like okay what am i
doing here i'm just sending clicks to
plenty of fish and i make you know seven
dollars per click margin and i'm just
like i doesn't what am i doing here
could i apply the same skill to
a brand that i create to a product i
genuinely believe in to a
an education app that i make whatever
and they they go on to do some pretty
great things so i've noticed that that's
one more
um and there's there's there's actually
a few other archetypes that i i don't
want to spend the whole episode doing it
like teachers is another one i met the
founder of alibaba
jack ma he was a former teacher
and um when did you meet him
i met him in college there was this uh
trip organized if there was this thing
called kairos which they named yeah i
did 100 top 100 college entrepreneurs
and it was a total horse like we
applied the night before we had we were
they didn't know anything about us and
we got in because like they i went to
duke and they needed a quota of a kid
from duke and so they got we got into it
even though we had done nothing
and um
and just to show you how like fake the
world is we got into that hundred
entrepreneurs thing
uh the event took place at the new york
stock exchange they had it like shut
down because the the guy who started it
his dad's like mega loaded and super
powerful bill clinton came to speak so
it seemed like this ultra legit event it
was not legit at all like it was like
just a total party and meet up for like
random college kids like the forbes 30
then cnn shows up and i get on cnn and i
have this clip of me pitching my sushi
restaurant on cnn as like the next big
thing and cnn runs it as like oh college
breakout success here this business is
one of the best businesses in college
right now so it's like oh if you believe
cnn you would think oh this is like a
great business idea that they're
featuring on cnn no it just happened to
be that i was in front of the camera and
cnn didn't give a they're just
recording stuff and putting it on
putting another filling air time you
know they didn't care there's no filter
uh there's a quality filter and then at
the end of that they were like
hey you know through our connections we
got the sea of alibaba to pay for all of
us to go all expenses paid here to china
for a week to hang out with him and see
their headquarters and all that so i got
to go on that with jack ma with jack ma
and we talked to jack ma and jack ma
tells the story and he goes
um
people were asking what are the keys to
success and he goes in china there's two
successful ceo types can i guess yeah go
teachers teachers one he was a teacher
yeah military
correct okay i don't know how you knew
that that was amazing have i told that
story before you just knew that it's a
guess
yeah he was like military um
you know the rigor of operations uh that
you need in business like there's no
better training for that than the rigors
of military and the systems and the
timing the production the
detail-oriented nature he's like so any
manufacturing business in china
the best leaders the best ceos are
ex-military and then he goes for the
non-factory type businesses like in
alibaba
teachers
tend to do pretty well he goes and we
said why you know that doesn't make any
sense to me
and he goes
a teacher is one of the only professions
where
the success of the student matters more
than the success of the teacher
like they care more that they're the
people under them succeed he goes in
management that is you know the best
principle for breeding great managers is
if you're like a teacher and your
success was not in how high you climbed
but how great your managers became
and um so that was his his reasoning i
don't know if that was correct that'd be
sick uh but i thought that was tight i
can't believe i've never heard that you
tell me that story that you got to go to
meet jack ma that's actually bad ass
yeah there was some crazy stories there
but we have some other stuff we should
talk about let me tell you about
something um go to rockautorockauto.com
all right i'm going rock auto like auto
like car okay yeah all right i'm on a
craigslist looking ass site what uh what
is the traffic this is a sampler classic
here
so
this company is called the rock auto
rock auto i don't know oh my god 20
million monthly yes
okay so i was listening to
an mma podcast michael bisping's podcast
and he does this ad read he goes if
you're buying car parts go to rock
rockauto.com they've got every car part
you could ever want
and i had never really heard of a uh
i know toyo or something like that tire
sponsors a lot of like sporting events
so i understand you know like it's a lot
of like meathead car people but i've
never heard of an auto parts other than
like napa and the famous one
and i went to this website rockauto.com
because they were sponsoring a bunch of
podcasters and it's the most bare-bones
site i've ever seen and i was trying to
do research on it and there's close to
nothing out there there's a few articles
from like five six seven years ago but
basically started by two brothers i
think in michigan they've got over a
million parts
and uh
the traffic is nuts so according to
similar web it's like north of 20
million and look at the source mostly
all direct
and so these guys this so this must be
something that um car
uh whatever repair shops go to order or
just customers are going no it's meant
for um
um just individuals just nerds just guys
who are tinkering or if you just like
wow for example something broke on my
car and i just like i just need this
little part i could replace it on my on
my own just like a little like door
handle thing and so i was like trying to
figure out where to get it and they had
it
no way so do they own the do they like
inventory parts themselves so they don't
so what they do is they connect with
dozens of or hundreds of suppliers and
they just have this like intricate
system of distributors uh all over the
the country and they send you the part
they need and their goal is to have uh
the like one part for every car that you
need so if you ever need anything for a
car
they can get their hands on it you know
kind of like how bezos said if there's a
book in existence we should sell it and
that's kind of auto part and i was
thinking about this for a few different
reasons the first is
with ecom i was like what doesn't amazon
crush it in and they don't crush it in
hardware so like home depot style stuff
right uh homedepot.com is like the
fourth or fifth or sixth something like
that largest uh retailer in the world
still and they've not gotten hurt at all
with amazon really or a little bit they
have but not in terms of like buying
screws online and another thing is auto
parts whether for cars or motorcycles
and so there's this company called
revzilla um
who was recently acquired for like 500
million dollars and they sold motorcycle
gear motorcycle parts and then i was
looking at rock auto and then i was
looking at a bunch more and it's
incredibly fascinating because there's
not that many new people in this space
but it seems like a pretty huge space
you know
morgan stanley had this report and they
said like it's a 70 billion a year
industry
but i just looked up the ceo of rock
otto he looks like jeff bezos before
basis got ripped
yeah it's like he looks like hch
yeah he looks like the before photo of
jeff bezos yeah
and uh it's amazing i think it's
interesting i've always thought the
space because i i something broke in my
car like i said and i tried to like
figure out how to buy the part and it
it's a pain it's a it's it's a pain but
the problem with this is is that you'd
have to have so many skus
um i mean yeah like i'm looking at like
bmw like i have a bmw x5 bmw x5 or
not even not even that if you just go to
bmw it's like you can look at a car from
1939. it's like okay here's the model so
here's the makes in 1939 and then you
could find a part for the cooling system
of the 1939 bmw blah blah blah like it's
amazing right
it's so hard it's a real it's a really
hard problem to solve for but what's
interesting is i don't think this is a
demand problem which is cool solving for
demand problems suck solving for
technology problems rocks if you could
figure out how to build a mouse trap
that's far better than figuring out like
are mice even going to go into this
thing right um you know what i mean
absolutely so that's why
you want to be supply constrained not
demand constrained when you use yes when
you do something
and this it's just incredibly
interesting to me and i think in order
to get popular on this you just would
crush
uh seo you and and
and that's how you'd have to do it and i
think that you could do it by sponsoring
a lot of youtubers and things like that
and uh it's just an interesting business
that i don't think has has has taken off
like a or an interesting industry i know
amazon's thought about going into that
space but it's pretty fast but this is
worth i bet you rock auto i was looking
online trying to like triangulate some
of their stuff and i found some old
interviews but if they i i would think
they have to do at least 100 million in
sales
and i don't think they other than the
recent podcast stuff if i if i bet you
they don't spend any money on marketing
other than like sponsoring like maybe
like some car shows
wow
unbelievable
uh that's crazy right that's a good find
great fine great find got to give you
props on that one that's it go to their
similar web and look at if you look at
where their traffic is coming from
virtually 100 percent practically all of
it is coming from search and direct
so people typing in rockauto.com
amazing uh what else you got what's this
hotel thing you got
okay
i'm gonna start a hotel
i don't know if i'm going to do it today
i'm definitely not going to do it today
but i'm going to do it soon can let me
explain what i'm going to do okay so
there are
i
went and met with some like olympians
the other day this guy who is this
olympian dmv he's a runner he heard that
i liked running and uh he asked if i
wanted to get dinner
i went and got dinner with him and like
eight of his athletes so he like was an
olympian and then now has an agency and
he has like 41 track and field athletes
not really popular for most people for
me it was cool and i could like i knew
who they were like a triple jumper a
miler whatever and i was talking to them
about money and they don't make anything
like
like some of them like have little
airbnbs on the side or they bought a car
to put on toro and one of them got a is
an american record holder in her event
another one um
won a gold medal and so anyway
i was interested in that because i was
like man if i wanted to like pay you to
be my coach i bet you i could get you to
do that like you can't be that expensive
and i started thinking that uh have you
heard of ufc how they have this thing
called the performance institute yeah
yeah they built these uh
like kind of
state-of-the-art ufc gyms where the
athletes can go train but i think it's
also kind of a tourist not tourist
destination but it's like uh
there's a public-facing component to it
right like you can i don't think there
is because when i've only heard about
this
when i've heard about this i'm like i
want to go there i want to work out
there i would do they have a hotel i
would love to stay there
and
i think so i think i could create a
hotel or a piece of like a large piece
of property and here's how i'm going to
test it
so in this order here's what i'm gonna
do
i think i could figure out is is there
demand for this and the way that i could
do it is i could get a bunch of these
olympians
the idea first is is it a demand for
this this being what it just
i think i can create like a resort
like uh where you go to just to train
and work out
with competitive athletes okay
so and i think i can convince the
competitive athletes to live there for
most of the year as like a training
place and they do a camp in the morning
and train for the rest of the day and
get paid to do that
gotcha okay i think i could solve that
and the way that i would try and solve
for that is i'm gonna contact like a
really nice hotel i'm gonna explain to
them what i'm doing then i'm gonna
contact
some of these athletes and be like hey
i'm going to pay you this much money i'm
going to charge these people a hotel fee
plus a fee on top of that and i'm going
to give you a cut of the money and i
think i can host an event at some of
these places and and make it work so my
brother-in-law who's been on the pod
before brother aaron for the og
listeners that remember him
he loves jiu-jitsu and he loves any
combat sports he loves training boxing
he loves training muay thai he loves
training jiu jitsu
and he wanted to create this thing so
he's created this thing called bali
fight club and what he's doing is almost
exactly what you're talking about so
he's like all right i need to create
like an mma style vacation so he's like
basically a lot of people are interested
in like going to bali being on a beach
and going to like a resort he's like so
he used to live uh near bali so he's
like oh i know
like i know the perfect spot for this
where there's a bunch of little villas
and the villas are like just dope like
you're you're on the most beautiful
beach you're in a private villa there's
like a chef that's like cooking for
everybody and all that stuff and each
family gets their own villa or each like
kind of like
resident would get their own or you can
buddy up or whatever
and um so there's all these little
little huts little villas and it's right
on the beach and then he's like dude the
best kind of like trainers in the world
for for combat sports or often in
thailand he's like i'm gonna get so he
met a pro boxer when he was on vacation
in mexico and the guy's like okay i'm in
and so he has like a pro boxer a project
guy and a pro muay thai guy and they're
gonna come on the trip too
and they want a vacation also and
they're basically like yeah we'll train
the the people
and they're like you get to train like
an athlete trains we're gonna do two a
days you're gonna have a massage in
between to like kind of recover the body
so we're gonna treat you like you're
gonna get to train like a pro athlete
trains while also being on vacation and
the whole thing is like whatever like
five grand or something like that five
six man and this is live
this is what he's creating right now so
he's basically he's got like two people
he's just waiting till he gets to like
eight people and when there's eight
people like the trip will happen um and
so
so that's what he's doing which is very
similar to your idea but instead of
being a hotel it's more like a a getaway
like a like a
like i would do a ghetto i would do
getaways that i would do getaways at
first and then eventually i would
acquire a piece of property within an
hour of a major uh international airport
right you do it in the us
yeah like i think you do it in austin
probably because austin is becoming like
a mini center of like health nerds right
um i think that you could
maybe do it in california you for sure
could do it in like a boulder or florida
somewhere
in florida yeah i think you could
amazing yeah i think that's a cool idea
i think it's sick especially because the
get the getaway is a great mvp for
something like that right and it's easy
builds up the momentum and that's not
hard to do
um so yeah i feel like that's that's
pretty great
let me tell you one more thing go to
manuals so it's called like manuals like
uh like a like a owner's manual manuals
lib
lib like library
manualslib.com
the ultimate manuals library
so it's a website
that's just full of manuals okay but get
this oh this is great like i was
building some i'm assembling something i
don't have the manual i need to fix
something i don't have the manual it's
just here it's like here's my kitchenaid
yes this website according to their
about page so the way that you find out
if a business is interesting is you if
you they make money through advertising
you scroll down and you click advertise
with us and you find out about them yeah
they according to their media kit they
get at least 16 million monthly uniques
of which 90 nearly is from search okay
they've got a brown 3.8 million uh
products on there with 5.2 million
manuals 106 000 brands and 3.2 terabytes
of data indexed
hilarious dude they just
have every manual they scan it
and they like seo the out of their
like rankings for when people but it
gets more interesting it gets more
interesting i i was researching this
i cannot find anyone on linkedin anyone
online who mentions these guys or works
there i can't find a thing about it i've
looked all over the i found one person
who on their linkedin says that they
were a freelancer and they're based out
of europe that's like pretty much all i
saw their main competitor is this is
where it gets interesting their main
competitor is this company called owner
iq
and they own this website called
manualsonline.com
and owner iq it's kind of a weird
business but but basically they
if you're going to buy something i don't
know how they do it but it's kind of
like tech target that's another publicly
traded company does that they they they
sell data to retail stores or
brands that somehow helps them figure
out who's buying their stuff and they i
don't actually don't know what they do
with it but owner iq
owns manuals online and they do well
over a hundred million in revenue and
and manuals online is one of their
products is that nutty this is wild also
if you look at their like traffic uh you
know like they really grew
starting in like 2012
um they like shot up the ranks into
becoming like one of the top sites now
so it's definitely it was created in
2012 and it just like pretty
instantaneously like within the year
uh became an ultra popular
uh ultra popular site the uh yeah these
types of business print money now this
was a ad based business so i guess
they're trying to get you to like i'm
looking for a manual and i'm like a
manual for the thing i bought and then
i'm like i'm gonna buy something
else because i
i don't want to deal with this like kind
of what's so there's this company
there's this company called tech target
and they're publicly traded their market
cap is but they still do like nine
figures in revenue it's called tech
target and i believe if i'm not mistaken
tech target owns
um like websites like cfo.com
and a bunch of other websites where if
you are a buyer
uh if so they own security docs.com they
own techguy.com they own things like
that and so basically if you're the cfo
of a 5 000 person company and you are
the decision maker for buying like this
is like an oversimplification but like
you're gonna say our company now needs
to use quickbooks
instead of this other software that's a
10 million dollar a year product that
we're gonna have to purchase and so this
company called tech target will create
cfo.com and create news just hoping that
the cfo will read it when deciding
between quickbooks and this other
website and they'll figure that out and
capture their email and contact
information and sell it to quickbooks
and then all their competitors right so
basically it's rooted in
influencing what you buy
yeah that would make sense to me i don't
know what the manual one would because
that assumes you've already bought the
thing so i guess that's a little bit
different but um yeah these are
these are great little like kind of
secret jam businesses that
are um you know like when andrew
wilkinson came on we asked him you know
what type of business do you want to buy
high growth high profits
he said i want to buy a new zealand
business which is a business that is
just independent uh sustainable
um does not rely on like one you know
like facebook ads or something like some
paid channel to like to grow that could
change any minute it's not going to be
competed against by google and facebook
and amazon they'll never care to compete
against this and that's a new zealand
business that he can you know safely buy
these are to me new zealand businesses
that you you've identified two new
zealand businesses here
yeah they're neat i i think they're cool
i think that like tech target that i
mentioned they're based out of newton
massachusetts this other one rock auto i
think that they're in sorry they're in
madison wisconsin so where the
university of wisconsin is and then
manuals lib
they're like in croatia i can't find a
thing about them i can't find it i feel
like there's there's a business you can
create okay let's say you wanted to
create something like this uh i think
you could you'd have to look at okay
what's new what's a new thing where you
need manuals so maybe there's some new
product new types of products that are
out there that need something like this
like for example could be software
things like that but software is not not
new enough the other one you could do is
any professional search so like
well it's something that only dentists
are going to search for
that's like really obscure but really
important to them
maybe it's around you know certain tools
or the software that they use or like
you know manuals for the equipment that
they've bought
uh maybe it's you know treatment uh or
like prescriptions or something like
that and some people have tried to
create like a separate google for
doctors because doctors google the
out of stuff um but like you know i
think that's really hard one another the
other way the easier way but less
valuable is
you figure out how to rank at the top
for everything that a doctor would
search for and you just become the
definitive authority in
some profession whether it's car
mechanics or dentists or doctors or
insurance agents or whatever real estate
agents something that they have a lot of
searches for that's not like already
nobody's created the definitive central
repository of information for it that's
a perfect segue for what i'm about to
say now listen to this
speaking of dentists
it's not even a segway i'm adding to it
and i was reading this article about the
top creators on youtube this year number
three for the most popular creator of
youtube shorts is called dental digest
and it's a kid who makes here's the
description of his thing
satisfying dental reviews dental
education and dental lifestyle content
this kid's got 6.1 million subscribers
on youtube only doing dentist stuff is
that ridiculous
wow i'm looking at one of his right now
so and i think it says uh
what did he say uh like we are uh like
i'm a third year
dental student
uh his about yeah his about is third
year dental student wants to help you
discover your best smile it's satisfying
dental reviews dental education and
dental lifestyle content how crazy is
that he's represented by knight media
which is the the guy reed who we had on
who uh he came on podcast and he
represents mr beast also
amazing right
designer toothbrush from france 8
million views
dude number six on this list is also a
dentist dude what's going on
it must be that dental content is just
interesting for non-dentists that's the
only explanation for this because like
how many dentists are there they're
they're not even eight million dollars i
don't know but this guy
the dental gi just guy is that i don't
think he's doing like popping videos
where you like watch someone pull a
tooth i think he's like he's reviewing
products
reviewing yeah he's doing stuff that is
not like anyway it's kind of interesting
uh
so i don't know where we go with this
but that was so weird i just watched a
video it was so weird
it's weird right the world's funny i'm
sure there's so much opportunity out
there we've just identified dentists
manuals
auto part we've talked about so much
stuff just a
short amount of time what do you want to
do uh let's wrap it up i have some other
ideas but let's save those for the next
pod let's wrap it up with one other
topic um which one you want to do uh you
tell me you pick
do uh
i don't care let's do
uh
okay i'm not really ready to talk about
this okay i'll talk about this okay so
here's
um actually i kind of want to hear you
talk about this let's do this work week
creator economy thing we never really
got to talk about that so
i saw that adam uh adam ryan i think is
his name he used to be
president of the hustle something like
that like
yeah i led our sales team he worked for
me leading sales so he worked for he was
kind of like your number two guy
basically at the hustle for a period of
time
and
he had left he went did a couple things
i don't know exactly he was like yeah
you're a competitor or something like re
recourse or recount i don't remember
yeah so he did some education thing i
don't know what happened i guess he left
that or it didn't work out or something
like that so he is he came out with a
new company recently
and uh it's called work week and so like
describe
give people like this simple description
of what it is and then
i want to hear your opinion on it i
don't entirely understand what's the url
workweek.com.com i think it's dot com i
think they got a nice domain there
workweek.comworkweek.com
and so it looks like so it says
workweek.com it says um what's there
i'll read about it it says a new kind of
media company so it's creating a media
company it says you want to follow
people not institutions so i think what
he's doing is there's a bunch of
creators that have their own niche so
like maybe this dentist guy would have
been a fit so it's like um
some guy named jared devchevsky who's
doing the healthcare huddle which would
be like i don't know was it like a sub
stack or something like that it was like
a newsletter
yeah and it's all about healthcare so
he's like he's covering the vertical of
of healthcare there's nicole who's
covering the vertical of fintech there's
the skype matthew who's covering the
vertical of cannabis and um i think they
were already creating content so they
were already content creators he kind of
like is scouting them and saying okay
uh they have a good newsletter let's say
um and he's like kind of like bringing
them all under one umbrella i think he
gets the rights to their content and
in exchange for distribution and money
is kind of my guess the website's very
nice i like the design of the website
very much um but this idea is kind of
interesting to me and you're you're my
go-to on the media side and i know you
you like you like adam and you're not
going to like you know say this is a
terrible idea or
you know
i'm just going to say it's a great idea
if you don't believe it so i want to
know what is your honest opinion of this
idea because you know media better than
anyone the way okay a few things the way
that it's positioned now it looks like
it's just an ad agency
which in itself isn't like horrible like
we represent these creators yes right i
think the hard part here is that the
creators that they represent
are nobodies like maybe there'll be
somebody's one day right but at the
moment this cannabis
health yeah i've never heard of any of
these people the yeah the cannabis thing
it looks like the the guy dm me one time
he had like 2 000 subscribers like the
healthcare guy has 500 followers on
twitter so not not a huge fan yeah and
and so i think uh the problem i mean
it's not really a problem you're just
building an ad agency i think but in in
workweek's case it's kind of a challenge
because you don't have any ad inventory
to sell yeah you do
so that i think it's gonna be really
hard i think it's gonna be a very hard
business i would never raise money for
this i think it could be a really cool
business that potentially like
makes money but from a creator's point
of view i have a few perspectives
first of all
i i don't love the language a new kind
of media company it's it doesn't it's
anyone who possesses themselves
that's basically a big mistake which is
positioning yourself only to other media
people
yeah yeah and like they don't care
they're not your customer anyways right
like that's not who you want i guess
this is the landing page for a creator
it's just jargon is what it is but uh
whatever that's that's a mistake that's
easily fixed um the from a creator's
point of view i think a few things one i
think this whole creator economy thing
is incredibly over hyped i think that
the vast majority of people who are
going to be able to make a living from
this is um
is okay so let's small let's do the
steel mining thing so
it's so when you say create a economy is
over-hyped that means something
different to everybody because everybody
has their own perspective of like is my
opinion overhyped well how do i know so
tell me what are people saying about the
creator economy that you think is
incorrect so people are saying that the
creator economy is this like new economy
everything's new um that now anyone with
the voice can make a living
and
that's what that's yeah i don't draw
banning you strawberry you gave them a
loser voice
while you said their argument
which is hilarious
so they say that anyone okay i'm gonna
try and actually do it the right way um
a lot of people think that like the
creator economy it means that uh a
variety of different people more than
ever before can create stuff that is
seen by by people and they can make a
living right um
that is true in that there are more than
ever before
but the ratio of people that are going
to succeed is still really small and i
think it should be small only the best
should survive
and the best likely
don't necessarily need you
um or at least they wouldn't be silly
enough to sell you their ip or their
content you know
no one would be crazy enough to do that
you know that it's the whole reason why
caller daddy bailed and started their
own thing um and so it's kind of like a
paradox in that the ones that you can
acquire you don't want to acquire and
the ones that you want you cannot
acquire because they're too savvy or you
acquire them right you did it all right
you bet on them early they did in fact
they fail and then when they blow up
they're like i'm gonna leave and you're
like ah but i bet everything on this
creator
this is a personality and when they
leave i have no recourse i have no
leverage
exactly it's just like the there's a
reason why none of the um
what's that thing called uh that was on
twitch and on youtube
what's it called it was called an mcn a
multi-channel network so one big one's
called maker's studio i think that's
what that's the one you're referring to
yeah and it actually had a big exit i
think yeah they they kind of like lucked
i wouldn't okay luck is a little
disparaging but like the business kind
of wasn't working but they had a they
got a
fantastic exit to disney and then you
know
and the business fall apart good for
them yeah
right so they timed it well where disney
bought it before the truth actually came
out but i think what the truth is now is
that
maybe these things can work but
likely it's going to be needlessly hard
yeah the same thing happened on twitch
uh ninja became the number one gaming
star in the world when fortnite became
the number one game in the world and
ninja got picked up by red bull and
ninja was getting paid millions of
dollars every single month by both fans
as well as advertisers the guy was bank
making 30 million dollars a year and
this team that had bet on him luminosity
they were basically like they acquired
his rights to the commercial rights to
his channel it's all under contract how
much did they spend
you know earlier they didn't spend much
right because he had no he had no
following at the time so it's kind of
like you know adam going and acquiring
health care huddle at 500 followers
you know pick up pick up the option on
the cheap you say this guy's really
talented he could become something
someday so luminosity had him under
contract
but uh he was like yeah hey luminosity
um i'm not sharing any revenue with you
and they're this is my fictional account
of what happened but they're like
but the contract
he's like yeah i just i i don't think
that's fair
uh if you want to go try to enforce this
you can but you know i will basically
drag you through the mud as like trying
to bring me down which is like the worst
thing you can do for acquiring new
players is
have everybody know that ninja is so
unhappy with you and does not want to
deal with you um and ninja feels like
you screwed him and so illuminati said
to sit quiet and shut up and just like
take the l so they you know they weren't
getting paid the full amount or whatever
i don't know all the details but like
they weren't sharing the revenue that
they should have shared uh they still
got to kind of be branded on him you
know be associated with his brand but
they they didn't get the upside of their
great bet and then loaded was this
talent agency said ninja goes loaded and
loaded is like work week and they had
all the stars they had all the top
streamers on their thing
and uh sure enough ninja starts getting
a deal with samsung and now these deals
are getting big and he's getting equity
deals and this mouse peripherals company
accessories company
and um guess what ninja's not with
loaded anymore right because
uh why do i need loaded like um i can
just do this on my own they're taking
too much
and you know same thing happened with
doctor disrespect he goes and leaves for
a different agency that's going to take
less and you know like you're it's a
race to the bottom as i say where you're
competing with everybody wants these
stars to be in their like roster and the
next guy will do it for less because hey
if i can get the top star
like that's just good for me even if i
even if they're a loss leader even if i
don't make money off them and so the
talent basically has ended up ended up
what happened to those two companies
luminosity and so luminosity and the
esports team still exist um
they just you know they they didn't get
the
it's like the whole thing was based on
we're gonna acquire this talent we're
gonna train them we're gonna promote
them we're gonna cross promote all the
players with each other and we're gonna
build stars and we're gonna have this
like portfolio of stars that like bring
in all this money but like that
basically got like torpedoed and anybody
who's smart knows this now
there might still be one or two teams
that the
team brand name is like the yankees um
where it ends up becoming valuable like
i think faze clan is trying to go public
in a spack right now which is like crazy
to me um and you know they had the same
thing the number one streamer they had
this guy tfu he was like uh let me out
of my contract i don't want to be with
you guys anymore
because he was getting great money he's
like why am i giving 20 30 40 to these
guys i don't want to do that and so he's
like let me out and they're like no he's
like let me out and it was like free
tifu became like the big thing the fans
are always going to be on the side of
the personality that they fell in love
with they're never going to be on the
side of the team
and it's what's going on in the nba
right now
so this business i think i think
like can can these types of businesses
work yes
but if you it depends what your goals
are if you want to start like a tech
company or like a vc thing like
maybe i wouldn't go this route because
i think it'd be it's going to be a huge
headache that doesn't mean it can't work
but i also think that one of my biggest
fears is
starting something in the prime of my
youth when i have the most amount of
energy which is for most people in their
30s and 40s they have a lot of energy
they've got some wisdom and they still
got some time to create something and
you go down this path and you look back
after toiling for five years and you go
that i i
we should have done this other thing
right and i think there are potentially
other opportunities that are even
similar to this in that space where i
hope that a pivot can be made otherwise
that that five year looking back is
likely going to happen that's a good
point there's like a graph that's like
um like energy starts at this high in
your 20s and just goes sort of like down
over time which is like energy which is
like not just like your actual energy
but the amount of time you can amount of
your energy you're going to get to put
towards your work so like you know oh
you got married or you get you're good
you're getting a relationship a little
bit less time you have kids less time
you have like you know let's say other
responsibilities come up in your life or
you're just
you're more you get more fatigued you
know when i was in my 20s i used to work
15 hours a day that wasn't i wasn't
super productive but i was throwing 15
hours a day at the problem i remember i
slept in the office 200 nights one year
when i was like 24 25. and so
that was like max energy now i work on
average five hours a day
and um like so energy goes down but then
wisdom goes up judgment goes up skill
goes up and so in your 30s the lines
like cross it's like the highest energy
you're gonna have while you have some
good wisdom and judgment and then in
your 40s your wisdom and judgment goes
up but your energy goes down and it's
like you know not the peak anymore
that's at least my my opinion of it yeah
and my point with that is we are in this
crazy world at the moment where if you
want to work in the creator space
there's a few routes that people go a
lot of people are creating like little
pieces of software that they hope to
sell for 5 10 15 a month right like two
creators yeah yeah we're two creators
and i'm like i don't i wouldn't do that
i think that those businesses nine out
of 10 times are going to fail 99 of the
time they're going to fail you know you
look at the difference between a buffer
which is like a five dollar twitter
sharing tool it did good or it's doing i
mean it did well but it like plateaued
versus like a hubspot or a hootsuite
that like scaled way beyond that because
they sold the same thing but this two
we're using right now riverside we use
this thing to record this
you know they charge whatever i don't
know nine or twenty dollars a month or
something like that to random ass
podcasters like us
and uh you know they're hoping to be
you know it's hard to imagine a world
where a business like this gets to like
50 million in revenue right yes it's
very hard and and and so
i think of creators and i think of that
space i'm like uh man that's gonna be
really hard like have some people done
it yeah mailchimp did it but like
there's way less
like it's really challenging and um
another way you could go is like do this
like ad
route and like that could be cool as
long as you don't want to hire a lot of
people you just want to make a lot of
profit early on but if i was in this i
would totally look at the markets and
the markets are like all about this dow
if you like use the word dao and
web 3 in your memo or your deck like
you're gonna raise money
right like it's pretty crazy it's all
it's just so i'm just like just go over
the go it's far easier
to chase the market or just get in the
mix
than it is to maybe do what you like
strictly or passionate about this brings
me to one thought that's been rolling in
my head and i didn't want to bring it up
because it's like what does this have to
do with anything but you actually kind
of tied it in that nicely which is
there's a certain luck with your time
with the timing of free agency so i
thought about this with basketball
because um this funny thing happened in
basketball where
every year the like salary cap changes
it goes up or down based on how much
revenue is being made and then like
every seven years they like renegotiate
the overall deal between players and
owners and so like there was a time in
the like kind of 90 late 90s or whatever
where players could it was like they
could just get these huge like 200
something million dollar contract seven
year eight year there was no like limit
to the number of years
and then owners got wise that the next
negotiation they're like hey like this
guy used to be good in year one of the
contract by year eight he was totally
washed up and i'm still paying them 50
million dollars so like
let's make the maximum length of the
contract five years and the players like
okay so like basically whenever you
become a free agent which as a player is
your time to go negotiate your deal
um like
it really mattered like magic johnson
back in the day i think he signed a deal
where he he had a 20-year deal where he
made one million dollars flat per year
what and like it was like at the time it
was the fattest contract because he was
magic johnson but like what magic
johnson made was nothing he was making
one million a year a scrub today and the
nba will make more than one million a
year so just the timing of like barely
over the minimum what's the minimum half
of the money was like yeah like
something like that like 500 600 000.
and so um you know magic johnson just by
being in the 80s which wasn't that long
ago
like missed out on hundreds of millions
of dollars probably a billion dollars
total like a star like that with
off-court endorsements would end up
making a billion dollars over their
career so
you know that's just like luck of timing
okay well there's also a luck of timing
in when it comes to business not just in
like oh you gotta time the market like
oh
you know let's say the market's going
good and my company got acquired because
everybody felt all the acquirers were
flush with cash versus a recession not
even that what i'm actually talking
about is like as an entrepreneur
the time like the random time when you
free up like you quit your job or your
company gets acquired or like whatever
that thing was
there's so much luck involved in like
what's going on in that moment totally i
absolutely we have a friend uh sully who
came out he was episode one of the
podcast and he says the story which is
like you know i was at microsoft i quit
my job
i went home just to my family's house in
florida and i was just kind of like okay
well what the hell am i gonna do now
and so he didn't have a grand plan but
he had his what the hell am i going to
do now moment at the same exact day that
the facebook launched its app platform
so he's like i was doing nothing
facebook launched his app platform so i
was like okay i want to build a facebook
app now whereas if he was just still
employed or had a different idea six
months earlier and he would have been in
the middle of that he would have never
built that app which have never led to
him come to silicon valley getting
acquired and getting his first million
dollars and then that turned into so
much more and like it's not to say all
of his success was luck obviously he did
a lot of good things but there is some
luck of just when you're free
and like what's going on in the market
like where are the waves happening like
right now we're doing i'm doing all this
stuff like at this e-commerce company if
i didn't have this e-commerce company i
would have been all in on web3 i would
have been investing more building more
maybe started a company in that space
because i would have been free to do
that at a time when that's the obvious
thing to do right now is go work
on web3 invest in web 3 and build in
web3
or ai or whatever there's like two or
three things going on right now where
it's like that's the that's definitely
the thing to do but if you're occupied
you can't do it
and so yeah and that's that's a little
bit of my point which is i think that
i think that if you create a restaurant
that's really good and like momofuku or
milk bar like
momofuku or like that cake like it's not
particularly like it's not really
different it maybe is slightly better
but like whatever he made it work and he
became incredibly wealthy that guy david
chang and it's a cool gig whatever it's
awesome that will work in the 1920s as
well as in the 2020s um so you could
pull off no matter what there's
some stuff that you can just make work
and if you just give enough time you'll
make that work but then there's other
things where it's like there's this
tidal wave coming and if you just catch
the wave even if you're shitty it's
gonna be awesome um i think michael
acton smith is his name the guy who
started calm he told me that he was like
i felt like he was like i didn't know
anything about meditation but i was just
able to talk to a couple people and i
felt like there's this huge wave coming
and if i could just paddle just a little
bit and catch that wave success is gonna
be incredibly easy right and he told me
that and i was like oh that's so you're
you're totally right if you just catch
the right thing at the right time and it
doesn't seem to be the right thing at
the right the right time but kind of
around the right time and kind of the
right thing it happened with us at the
hustle newsletters we our newsletters
weren't this like tidal wave of a
business you know our exit wasn't like a
20 billion dollar like
but it was like a nice like oh it just
so happened that we caught this little
trend at the right ish time
well there's a i think most people would
get some of the like so so the one part
of what you said which is just like
oh this market's ready to exp like the
market is ready so it's like market
timing i think everybody kind of gets
market timing oh that's a thing it's
important but it seems very external
it's like oh
i can't control that and it's like you
hope you get it and sometimes you don't
you try to look out for it but you never
know
what i'm talking about is even
the one thing you can control which is
your own personal availability timing
and so i think this has two things one
is like you should recognize that if
there's a if there's a like a wave going
on and you're occupied with something
that's not ideal
um
like get the out of there because
you just needed to be free right now it
doesn't matter what you go do in that
space you don't even need the idea you
just need to be available you need to be
single when all the you know when all
the the eligible bachelors are walking
down the street if you're not single if
you're not on the street because that's
that's when the parade was going on
you're not gonna get you're not gonna
get picked up and so it's like
being available at a certain time is
really really important and also that
what that means is don't pick up a
mediocre project
that's going to occupy you because you
just think oh well you know i think this
can't hurt i'll make some good money
i'll like i'll meet some people it's
like well it will hurt in this silent
invisible way which is you're going to
become occupied
and that likely has no longer in the
market for good luck to happen to you
and that lack of focus
is
more likely than not what ruins most
everyone who tries to do anything
interesting i tweeted out this thing to
like get to do a little research i i i
kind of up i tweeted out hey um
what what is
the biggest problem in your work life
right now like i don't care if you're
mega successful or if you're uh just
like a mcdonald's like employee whatever
doesn't matter who you are everybody's
got like some career challenge that's on
their plate right now what's yours and i
said dm me and so i got a bunch of dms i
forgot how did you get what i should
have said is i'm not going to help
everybody because that wasn't my intent
i actually wanted to do research i
wanted to know what problems you had so
i could make content that like
maybe speak like if i know anything
about one of these problems great that i
could put it out there if that's a
common problem people have
and so
comment
because some people i didn't think would
be comfortable saying like the issue
like what they're struggling with
publicly yet
at least 100 i don't know 100 200
something like that it was a lot and um
and one of the most common ones was like
um
you know either some variation of i
don't know what i want to do with my
life but i know this ain't it
or
i kind of know what i want to do
but
i'm afraid to go do it like i'm doing
this other thing right now
and the answer to both of them is sort
of the same which is whether you know
what you want to do if you don't know
what to do if you know this is not what
you want to do the fail the first step
is make yourself single get out of the
bad relationship right like that is the
the app because it is taking up space in
a way that you're not your brain is not
going to like
properly assess the cost of that because
you're going to just see the small
benefits you're getting from it what
you're not going to see is that actually
you know you
nothing can fit in here because that's
there um i don't care if you're at
microsoft or wherever and so that was
like the number one and number two like
thing but to me they're the same which
is i don't like what i'm doing now
should i go do x or what should i go do
it doesn't really matter the answer to
both is the same which is you got to get
out of x if you're if you really like
care if you want this to get to that
amazing level like if you're okay with
it as is fine you're okay with it as is
but if you want more and this ain't
gonna give you more you gotta get rid of
it and that's the only decision you need
to make right now you don't have to make
the other decision yet
yeah
i completely agree i think that um just
like you just gotta get a swing i told
this to take enough swings you'll get
you'll get a hit we have this guy who
does uh for our ecommerce show he's
amazing he's so good at like website
optimization
and he's like hey i got i want to talk
to you like you know you told me i can
use this card one time which is like hey
give me some advice so i want to use it
which is like i kind of want to go do
web like i can't stop thinking about
web3 i'm super interested in it but i
don't know if i'm just like following a
hype train and what's going to happen if
the price is gonna crash and if it's all
a bubble and i don't know all these
things
uh and i got a good thing going for me
and basically i ended up talking him
like as i talked to him i didn't talk
him out of it i just let him talk out
loud to where it was like blatantly
obvious that he needs to throw away a
good thing
to maybe be working with you amazing
which is me i'm one of his clients he's
got a few clients his business is doing
gangbusters and he's very good at it but
he's sort of like unstimulated by just
like e-commerce at this point and he's
super curious about this other thing but
it's like how do i let this go this
brings in money and it's like i'm good
at it my brand is all my identities tied
to this
and it's like well okay i asked him you
know like i'll i'll read two bits of it
because in case this like helps people
which is i go do you only talk with your
employees via text messages or uh slack
well i meant like text format
right uh yeah i try to i try not to do
like calls i told them how many police
do you have can we do a call and i was
like
just type it here let's see if that
works
how many employees do you have
uh there's like i don't know there's
probably like 12 in the main in my main
ships of like actually maybe 15 of like
between the fund and content and
e-commerce 15 people probably associated
with it but that's a combination of
virtual assistants all the way up to
like ben who's like you know my
right-hand man i called the out of
ben but i just typed everybody else
um so okay so he he basically was like
here's what i'm thinking blah blah i
told him i go first question how much
runway do you have if live if life costs
you four thousand dollars a month to pay
for it
uh just make sure you have enough
savings otherwise you can't really make
this decision if you don't have any
money
uh yeah he was like i have you know like
six months totally liquid and i have
another six to twelve months that like
i could totally eat into without without
feeling bad um i think my when i go
whenever i talk to people i say 24
months
yeah i i just think that's a that's like
that's like safe that's very safe i
think you know
you could do it but that's like 100
we're talking like a hundred grand
yeah but to save up i mean that's what
that means is weight and i think waiting
is a very big cost to pay so you got to
be sure you're willing to pay the price
of waiting
okay so then i said all right uh you
presented me with three options but
really there's two you said i can take
on more clients and lose all my free
time no do not do this
you can keep your current clients and
have some free time and it's a pretty
safe path you could do that for six more
months and then like collect more data
if you're just not sure about something
if you don't if you don't have
conviction or you could quit what you're
doing get rid of all your clients
including me
and go all in on it it's the riskiest
most radical you should do this if you
know what you want to do
and it really just comes down to that do
you know what you want if so then go for
it do not wait do not hedge your bets i
said if you don't know what you want
then do path b where you collect
information but be really specific about
what you're trying to learn don't just
wait for waiting sake and just hope that
you'll feel more ready later talk to
yourself about what is it that you're
actually trying to figure out and then
figure that out in the next six months
um he's like he said some other stuff
blah blah blah and i was like
and at the end by the end of it i was
like um you gotta ask yourself these
three questions
if i wasn't afraid of failing which
which path would i pick because that's
what you really want to do
um then i said do you believe that if
you put your mind to something you're
going to succeed at it and i only ask
him this because i could see he's a star
he's really good at what he does so i
know he is the answer is yes if he puts
his mind to it he'll get good at
something
and then i said um so if you know that
if you weren't afraid of failing what
would you do
if you put your mind to it you could
succeed you believe that correct yes
okay then what should you do he's like
well then the answer is obvious i should
go do that thing so i ended up talking
myself out of i ended up talking one of
my star guys off of my team which kind
of sucks but so it happened
uh you know if it will soon like you
know who knows people get cold feet but
like he knows what the answer should be
now
from his own
like i just asked questions they were
leading questions yes but at the end of
the day they were questions and the
answers were very obvious uh to him and
it was like you know so why would i not
do this you know it all just traced back
to some version of like fear and anxiety
that's great i mean we're just never
going to see how this is you know you
only want fear and anxiety driving the
car they can be in the car yeah they're
a passenger but like
they're not allowed to hold the wheel
um
can we wrap up with one quick thing yeah
do you see uh
tyrone woodley is now fighting jake paul
uh yeah the other guy dropped out or
something
yeah
i'm crazy right what do you feel about
how you feel about that
so let down yeah let down as well yeah
woodley's just the most boring fighter
so that just sucks
so bored i'm so bored by this i wanted
tommy fairy to fight him um
dude jake paul though
i'm gonna pay money to watch this stuff
do you pay money to watch fights
yeah i pay when i feel like it's like
somebody i i really care about i want
like if it's a mcgregor fight i'll pay
yeah and i'll pay because hey i don't
want to hassle with like the bootleg
stream like crapping out at the wrong
time and also i feel like i'm gonna get
my money's worth whereas if it's just
like two if it's somebody i don't really
care about then i'll just watch clips or
i'll stream it or whatever like i'll
figure out another way but i won't
pay the 60 70 80 bucks for that what
website uh do you use hey what are we
trying to do here is you're trying to
knock me
allegedly are you a narc now
[Laughter]
do you use a good one
uh yeah do you have one that you go to
all the time i'll dm you some things
that i do uh
i used to use this website called
project free tv i don't think it's
around anymore and i would watch all my
free tvs tv shows on that now apparently
there's this thing called crack streams
which is pretty good
may have may have taken a glance at that
one yeah
but i do the same thing i i buy a lot of
them i don't know because it's got a z
in the name streams with a z
i also uh it's good i also um i pay for
youtube tv so i get a lot of stuff there
and i pay for espn so i get stuff there
yeah
so by the way you've heard this story in
the past about how um remember when dane
cook or yeah dane cook got popular did
you ever hear the story of how he got
popular was it from kazaa
yeah do you know what he did
no
genius distribution hack this is
one of the greatest growth hacks ever
when kazaa and limewire and all those
different like you know torrent type of
downloading programs were out there when
people used to download music and all
that i can't believe that stuff existed
he um
he created files that would say like
chris rock stand up or it'd be like you
know dave chappelle or eddie murphy best
stand-up and it would be four minutes of
chris rock and eddie murphy and then the
next 56 minutes would just transition to
dane cook
and that's how he got famous so people
were searching for those guys they would
download the thing thinking they're
getting an hour special of that guy
right it would start with that it'd be
like now dame cook and he would just
start with a joke
and like sure enough people would listen
and that's how he got like his
distribution that's how he got his name
out there initially well if you think
back to it like of course it didn't seem
the way that this way at the time but
the internet was so small
that i remember like i would wait for
wait for something to get released and i
like knew off the titles like and how
many seeders were on there i knew i
could get that one like i knew all about
it like you knew about kazaa limewire
you knew which ones to download for
which stuff and
now looking back i totally could have
been um i could i totally could have
manipulated it
yeah like i wouldn't have even thought
of that but maybe me today would have
thought of that back then but i don't
know
even when i heard that i thought it was
genius it's so genius that i'm like
skeptical it's true but uh but i've
heard it
i bet you that guy made so much money
because he made money if you were able
to make money when uh cds were 18
that was like the the best time in in uh
music and comedy and that because the
cds were like 50 or 80 cents or
something it was just a little piece of
plastic right that basically all went to
zero and now it's just only live shows
back then you've had live shows plus
the cds and stuff plus and then he got
into movies he i think he became like
the most popular comedian in the world
for like two years remember that movie
he was in with jessica simpson i love
that movie jack shepard checkout or
something like that
yeah where he like runs like a sam's
warehouse i love that i loved i used to
love date cooking he's like he's like
dave
or coldplay you're like embarrassed to
talk about it
yeah except for me i'm like what this is
good music what's the problem
um all right that's the episode
[Music]
you